hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my arrow episode 11 video
midnight City so before the episode
aired there was a bunch of new
information that was released they cast
Jimmy Olsen on Supergirl so I'll talk a
little bit about that and there were
some some details about things from
behind the scenes on arrow so I'll try
to explain that too
I guess just to get through that stuff
first so one of the writers on arrows so
that they do have a set for the Lazarus
Pit they didn't say how they're gonna
use it but they do say that they make a
lot of Hot Tub Time Machine jokes on on
the set when they're walking around so
just because they have a Lazarus Pit
doesn't mean we're gonna see anyone get
resurrected or anything like that but it
is pretty cool to know that they have
one they confirm break is not a
metahuman on the show he's just he's
just a normal guy that's super super
tough
they're still trying to figure out Ray
Palmer's character so his storyline
isn't set in stone and the Suicide Squad
is confirmed to be coming back later
this season in present-day they wouldn't
say whether or not Cupid was gonna be on
the team and McCobb Brooks is the one
that they cast is Jimmy Olsen on
Supergirl
so he'll be like a giant Jimmy Olsen
he's a big guy okay so moving on to
arrow stuff just careful for spoilers
from the episode if you haven't seen it
yet starting with top five moments
number five Black Canary false starts
this episode is part two of what they're
calling the canary trilogy so that's
going to conclude with next week's
episode they're telling the story of how
Laurel takes the mantle part of that is
her getting her ass kicked I guess you
saw through the episode she fell a lot
she tripped a lot she got cut to shreds
and most of team arrow doesn't think
that she's up to the task
although I think most of them come
around by the end of the episode I know
it seems like they're moving really fast
but I do feel like they address the
issue of her not being ready to be a
superhero it's just that their need for
a symbol like the canary is more
important than their belief that Laurel
isn't ready so I think I think you'll
see a lot of training montages a lot of
Laurel getting better in the next
episode that fight with break is another
good example - so she knows when to cut
and run like there's no way she's gonna
be brick so obviously she's gonna have
to jump out that window that was
actually one of the best stunt sequences
of the episode I always like it when
arrow can give really badass stunts to
people that are not Stephen Amell
yeah he's the hero of the show he's
always gonna get the best stunts but
it's fun while he's away for them to
give those stunts that they would
normally give to him to other characters
I feel like them using this time to show
Laurel getting better as Black Canary
also gives them the opportunity to show
the other
sike characters like the other female
characters getting better becoming more
heroes in their own right moving on to
number four team Oliver and team Merlyn
will do anything to protect their
families when I say team Oliver I'm
talking about like the Masayo stuff
that's going on with the League of
Assassins in the flashback stuff with
China white team Merlyn obviously just
being Merlyn Anthea it wasn't really
clear in the previous episode but I
really feel like they were trying to
mere Masayo and Merlin's characters in
this episode they both do really
questionable things in the name of
protecting their family it's a little
clearer with masayo like you know he
loves his family Merlyn has been a
villain in the past so it's a little
harder sell but yes I do think that
Merlyn really cares about his family
it's just he's so twisted inside that
his methods are just way beyond what a
normal person would ever consider
acceptable you can't handle the truth
Roy was not wrong Thea is totally gonna
figure out what's going on for real like
the stuff that Merlyn did not totally
the details of how she's involved in
shit's totally gonna go down this is a
family matter that just makes things so
much more fun to think about when you
frame it in that context the overarching
narrative there there's some other big
stories that I think are going on that
I'll talk about it kind of makes you
think of Batman death in the family in
the part of Robin Robin dying is played
by the Sara Lance Canary arrow has a
long history of borrowing from some of
the best Batman stories which I think is
awesome that DC lets them do that if you
can't have Batman why not take one of
his best stories moving on to number
three
Felicity gives everyone a jump start I
feel like she has a second career as a
nighttime superhero therapist I hope she
gets paid extra for that there may be
things pretty fast I expected her to be
on the outs to kind of be circling all
the teams for a little bit longer but
she jumped back in really quick by the
end of the episode she was totally
helping Ray Palmer build more gear for
his atom suit and helping team arrow
replicate Sara's voice it wouldn't be a
team with Felicity to down that though
and I feel like the Ray Palmer character
doesn't work without the Felicity scenes
at least not yet with all the crazy
stuff that goes on each week with all
the racial ghouls stuff it's easy to
forget how important Felicity is to the
other characters
she's the mechanic that keeps the
Machine working and the Machine is team
arrow and in whatever is going to become
team Palmer or team Adam and speaking of
felicity scenes the way they opened the
episode that Oliver nightmare that's my
new favorite opening scene from any
arrow episode
moving on to number two Rochelle ghoul
is
looking for Oliver's body and may or may
not be faking masayo out this is
narrative symmetry the arrow always has
with the flashbacks where something in
the past always highlights something
that might be happening in the future
so Masayo being faked out by Amanda
Waller like her swapping the samples
knowing that Miss a was gonna betrayer
might say something about what rish al
ghul is doing in the present so maybe
Rachel Google knows that Messiah is
going to help Oliver so he's leading him
on in a bid to try and get to Merlyn
knowing that Oliver is gonna go back to
Starling right now it's not super clear
it's a little bit early so it might be a
little bit more complicated than that
but Rachel Ghul is the master assassin
and a master planner so any story that
he's involved in is always going to be
way more complicated than it seems
think about that Felicity scene at the
beginning that nightmare where she said
I think that Rachael Ghul is going to
use your humanity against you
so maybe Rachel Ghul is doing the same
thing to masayo knowing that he would
save his friend and my number one moment
from the episode danny brickwell takes
over the glades and it becomes arrow
no-man's land if you're not familiar
with the Batman story no-man's land it's
a story of how Gotham goes through this
giant earthquake a la undertaking
martial law is declared the United
States kind of draws a giant line around
it and says this is no longer part of
the United States because it's so awful
the Justice League isn't allowed in to
fix things just because it becomes such
a political problem it's not a problem
that can be solved with super powers so
Batman has to use the resources that are
left inside the city and his allies to
fix everything it's a really great comic
book so you should definitely check it
out
but it's kind of what's going on in the
glades right now I mean it's not a
carbon copy but arrow is inspired by a
lot of big Batman stories and it also
even resembles Dark Knight Rises just a
little bit you know for Gotham this kind
of left is its own little territory for
a while we're still in the middle of the
canary trilogy so what I'm wondering is
is if like the next mini arc like after
Oliver returns is going to be no-man's
land the story of how Oliver and team
arrow fixes Starling city so just taking
a step back let's look at how all the
characters shifted in the episode so
right now brickwell is the clear villain
of the series
raesha al Ghul is kind of floating in
the background he's very sinister but he
hasn't done anything overtly evil yet
Merlyn acting in the interest of his
family kind of you know riding the
between good and evil then you have team
arrow all good characters I'd be really
interested to see like where the battle
lines are drawn and what alliances are
made now that brick walls become such a
huge force in the city does that mean
the team Merlin and team arrow are going
to have you know some slight overlap I
don't know that they'll be budding up
anytime soon but I'm just holding out
hope for that Merlin Oliver fighting
scene whenever they're not finding each
other they kind of team up in a
temporary alliance to fight Rochelle
ghoul or someone else that Oliver thinks
is worse than Merlin so here's my big
question for you guys
now that brickwell has become the clear
villain of the series or at least for
right now in the demarcated is territory
do you think the team Merlin and team
arrow will help each other out at some
point well you guys think about that
just to talk about some of the easter
eggs I spotted so I already talked about
the Batman story no-man's land just to
reference the flash though and a you
know kind of a backdoor Easter Egg a lot
of people ask you know will canary get
her canary cry will Laurel get the
canary cry I don't think she's ever
gonna be a metahuman but if you look at
the way Pied Pipers powers work with the
sonic technology it's possible that they
could adapt that type of technology for
her at some point so if you want Laurel
to get closer to the canary cry in the
comics I think that's the way to do it
if you did spot any other Easter eggs in
the episode just right and below in the
comments but you know there was a lot of
other great stuff a lot of funny moments
that I just didn't fit into my video
like brickwell thinking of himself as
Julius Caesar or Felicity helicopter
rides so a lot of great stuff
the only real thumbs down I had in the
episode was the explanation of how
Amanda Waller swapped the Alpha so she
pulled a fast one on masayo
knowing that he was going to betray her
I feel like they didn't set that up well
enough I'm not really a big fan of when
shows actually to make this huge leap
without setting it up in a real clear
way the fake alpha was a really big deal
it was a really big part of the episode
if Oliver is supposed to be an analog of
Batman world's greatest detective he
should be able to put two and two
together they kind of did that at the
end of season 2 where he was able to
pull a fast one on Slade and who he
himself is a really smart person it
feels like sometimes they're kind of
inconsistent with that where it's like
the character is only smart when the
narrative needs them to be smart as
opposed to being smart all the time so
just in general I feel like all the
characters need to take a couple more
courses in detective work you guys can
let me know if you agree though does it
frustrate you when characters don't see
things that are right in front of their
face like yes this double crossing here
gonna double-cross me at some point I
know a lot of you guys have been asking
there been some IMDB descriptions for
future episodes for arrow and the flash
I'm not going to mention them in this
video you can talk about them in the
comments if you want just please use
spoiler tags they're just there been
liberal spoilers for what's going to
happen at the end of episode 12 and
what's going on in episode 13 as well as
some big stuff that's gonna be happening
on the flash - so I'm totally happy to
talk about that stuff I just I don't
want to put it in the literal video so
that's I kind of leave that for the
comments and for people asking about
agent Carter episode 4 I just I wasn't
able to start that video in time so I
decided to push it to Thursday
so I wouldn't be too caught up with my
arrow stuff tonight I'd rather have one
video post late than have two videos
post late so don't worry I'll talk about
agents of shield and the Black Widow
program and all that stuff in that video
I will be doing like an arrow flash Q&A
like I normally do I'm not exactly sure
when that's gonna post so you'll have
plenty of time to post questions it's
just that there's gonna be a game of
Thrones trailer tomorrow and so that's
it like at the top of my priority list
so why you guys wait for all that stuff
to happen you can click here to catch up
on the flash from last night and you can
click here for last week's episode of
arrow thank you so much watching so
let's all high-five I'll see you guys
tomorrow
you